diese sendung wird ihnen präsentiert von
b genießen sie cremige rezepte mit brk
monday cremiger genuss seit 1922
[Musik]
hallo guten tag ich bin stefano er hasst
du willst du übersetzen
komm her
jetzt kommt auch mit sie versteht dich
nicht ahmed kommt er fragt jedes mal
wann kommst du wann kommst du nur das
willst du auch mit seiner mutter
sprechen
[Musik]
er hat meine mama gesagt du bist wie
heißt das dass hier sagt man dem herz
herz mir gesagt du herz ja gesagt du
bist in meinem herzen
ich liebe dich
[Musik]
lieber ahmed wer weiß ob du dich noch
daran erinnerst wie du als kleines kind
vor dem krieg in syrien geflüchtet bist
wie dein vater stundenlang marschierte
und einen sack auf den schultern trug
das warst du liebe ahmed mit baumelnden
kopf hast du hunderte von kilometern
zurückgelegt um in den irak zu gelangen
alle gingen mit euch deine mutter deine
schwester und seine beiden brüder
eines tages wird dir deine mutter
bestimmt erzählen dass er damals kein
geld mehr hatte teure flucht gemeinsam
fortzusetzen
und dass sie dich mit deinem vater und
seinem bruder alleine weiter ziehen ließ
damit ihr das land erreichen könnten wo
man wie sie glaubte dich heilen könnte
die schweiz
das ist mein name ich will ihn anfassen
mach die augen zu und treue was schönes
wie wir es das letzte mal gemacht haben
schließt die augen
was siehst du siehst du die zwei
hübschen blauen fischer während eurer
zeit tobias quartier von viele menschen
umgeben die euch helfen wollten
aber dann ist der traum geplatzt
und wie im leiter spiel stande tier nach
knapp zwei jahren wieder ganz unten an
der leiter
[Musik]
das war an dem tag an dem ihr die
schweiz verlassen musste und nach
deutschland zurückgeschickt wurden
doch du bist lange genug in giubiasco
gewesen um ein bleibendes zeichen zu
hinterlassen
wer sind die freunde von ahmed und
pfarrer max hat ihre freundin
ich hab alles getroffen jetzt legt auch
mit in einer kleinen stadt in
deutschland
ich habe ihn besucht im legoland in der
nähe von legoland in deutschland das
heißt sie sind in ein anderes land
gezogen seien sie es ständig von einem
land ins andere
hier helfen sie können in deutschland
bleiben oder gar in die schweiz
zurückkehren
[Musik]
stellst du mal
weiter
da hatte
du darfst dir auch nicht schließen du
musst sie offen halten und nicht lachen
öffne die augen so ist das gut nicht
bewegen
mal sehen
das ist hier hinten zimmer 25
volkshelden aufstieg hier 25
kindergeld läuft da über die
familienkasse und die aber in ravensburg
aber die anträge gibt es entweder auf
den rathäusern oder vielleicht bei der
agentur für arbeit in fragen weil die
familienkasse gehört ja zur agentur für
arbeit
also das muss er denn auf jeden fall
beantragen für sein kind
[Musik]
und schaut da am himmel
warum fliegt es genau über uns
es bringt die leute zum nahen flughafen
vielleicht wollte es auch einen
hamburger
[Musik]
[Applaus]
letztes jahr habe ich euch von der
dublin-verordnung erzählt die bestimmt
dass asylsuchende sich in dem land
aufhalten müssen wo sie registriert
wurden
das heißt wo ihre fingerabdrücke
genommen wurden nach zwei jahren im
tessin ist die familie damit
einverstanden nach deutschland
zurückzukehren weil sie hofft dass
dadurch die mutter und die beiden
geschwister nachkommen können wie es
ihnen versprochen wurde
[Musik]
wo hast du das telefonieren getan
er weiß dass er heute um 14 uhr in
seinem zimmer sein muss um auf etwas
ganz bestimmtes zu warten
[Musik]
steckt abbas jetzt hallo mein kleiner
schau mal hallo anna geht's direkt mit
ich habe immer noch euer foto ich hab's
nicht weggeschmissen haben es auch nicht
weggeschmissen
es hängt neben dem fenster hast du schon
neue freunde gefunden
ein paar gehst du hast du italienisch
gelernt erinnerst du dich lernst du
jetzt auch deutsch italienisch kann ich
jetzt noch besser
das ist ja toll dass ich will dich was
fragen werde ich bin's jonathan toews
und jetzt musst du herausfinden wer das
ist wie geht gut wie geht's dir ich
vermisse dich mal richtig auch keine
einen zahn verloren hat fragt er
wir haben einige zähne verloren ich
schon ich 4
ich habe zwei verloren wir sagen dir
jetzt alle zusammen und schicken dir
einen dicken kuss
[Musik]
während der tafeln schokolade so oft bei
uns zu hause dass meine partnerin der
bora dich und faller maß zu messen
jeweils gleich mit zählte
und ich glaube dass unsere kleine
tochter ariella immer mehr freude daran
fand zwei große brüder zu warten
ariella heute morgen hat sich ariella
zöpfchen gemacht habe siehst du sie ist
dem pferd geworden wie ein pferd kommst
du heute nicht für uns heute nicht
nächste woche verstanden
in sieben tagen
da steht der schau
hallo wie geht's
[Musik]
gut
hallo giuliano
[Musik]
hast du das schon gekocht
ja ich koche jeden tag mit der hand da
nimmst du das glas schmeckt gut
vielen dank wenn meine mutter erst da
ist wird sich für euch kochen sie ist
die beste köchin der welt für mich
zumindest eine mutter sprich mit voller
maß dann kann er gleich alle übersetzen
[Musik]
woran glaubst du kannst
ich hoffe von herzen dass wir in weniger
als einem monat unsere bewegung haben
hoffentlich du weißt ja was für großes
herz mama hat
78 19 ich komme
[Musik]
ja
wir sind zu hause ein dual shot
[Musik]
warte wir müssen noch die ohren abspülen
so jetzt sind wir fertig
[Musik]
hier ist es zu kalt trieben ist es
wärmer
[Musik]
sind sie schon trocken er hatte sich
vorgestern die auf es fehlt nicht mehr
viel
[Musik]
marx am rechten ort
bertinelli sally und sabrina sie da die
tarife rooney von reduzierten arbeiten
er will nur
[Musik]
wenn ich das hasse wenn man mich morgens
weckt nur dass hier
[Applaus]
den wir wir haben heute unseren termin
endlich
karten kann sich alleine an und
ausziehen will sie allein ausgeführt
das wird dir dein papa das fragt dieser
esel so blöd und das hier weg damit
[Musik]
die frau schreibt damit du endlich zur
schule gehen kannst wenn du sie ärgerst
macht sie nichts mehr
willst du dass alle zur schule gehen nur
du nicht gehst du zur schule steht auf
[Musik]
guten abend doktor ameli hier spricht
der woran ich wollte unseren termin von
heute abend bestätigen
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob das schon weist wir
können euch bald wieder besuchen ganz
bestimmt
ja
das ist schön aber wir können dir nicht
sagen
vielleicht sind wir wieder dieselbe
gruppe vielleicht kommen anderen auf
jeden fall wird euch jetzt immer wieder
mal jemand besuchen und du erzählst wie
es in der schule läuft
das traurige an der geschichte ist dass
sie hier eine lebensform gefunden hatten
die ihnen etwas ruhe gaben
das war das wichtigste für sie bis jetzt
ist ahmed nicht einmal ärztlich
untersucht worden
das verstehe ich einfach nicht bei einem
kind mit dieser art von fehlbildung am
rücken wird bei uns sofort ärztliche
betreuung übernommen
damit es ein normales leben führen und
wieder gehen kann gehen
aber ja es waren diverse
rehabilitationstherapie um ahmed eine
optimale lebensqualität zu ermöglichen
ich hatte ihn bereits untersucht und
alles eingeleitet als plötzlich das
gestoppt wurde mit der begründung es sei
noch unklar wo er hin
ich war vor den kopf gestoßen denn je
mehr zeit vergeht desto schwieriger wird
es für das kind
[Musik]
selten sind runde stern ahmed unter
diesem schönen mond könnten wir ein
gebet sprechen damit die mama bald
kommen lieber gott
wir beten zu die unter diesen vollmond
macht das die mama but her kommen kann
und weiter wir beten zu dir unter diesem
vollmond wir hätten zu der unter diesem
form und nicht dass dem amt kommt wir
möchten sie so gerne wieder sehen
sie fehlt uns her ganz fest das kann
morgen nachmittag kommen wir nach
deutschland
am donnerstag können wir alle zusammen
nach ravensburg zum arzt wegen acht mit
morgen gucke ich gelben risotto du musst
also nicht kochen
manchmal sind wir schon da
[Musik]
fast genau auf dieser seite erwischt
mich nicht du mit deiner katze schon mal
[Musik]
und ob richtig erwischt
es riecht wunderbar das habe ich schon
so lange nicht mehr gegessen
wunderbar gelbe risotto
[Musik]
bravo
und verachtet stell dich näher an die
wand ich kann nicht nein du musst noch
eine große los ziehen und strümpfe
ausziehen
genau so macht es alleine großer junge
jetzt fahre ich noch mal runter oder
aber noch etwas zeit
da ich wird nichts
[Musik]
da ist das ass der hüftkopf sogar sagen
ja es stimmt ich konnte den film
da habe ich vielleicht 30 prozent die
nicht in der pfanne stehen hier habe ich
fast 100 es ist relativ wahrscheinlich
dass haben das operieren muss viel und
hier nur du musst operiert werden sie
dich hobby schafft es nicht
und nach der operation bekommst du diese
speziellen stiefel mit denen du gehen
lernen kannst und wie nehmen sie den
knochen mit einer operation und du musst
für zwei wochen ins krankenhaus
so wird der knochen wieder beweglich
dann machen sie wieder zu
sie setzen eine art eisen ein dass er
ein jahr lang drin hat dann wird dein
sohn gehen können ich bete zu gott was
war denn los ich habe gehört dass
geweint warum denn nachher mal wegen so
einer kleinigkeit einst du bei einer
herzoperation könnte ich es ja noch
verstehen aber das hier ist routinesache
willst du dass er gehen kann oder nur
ich will schon dass mein kind operiert
wird aber es tut mir weh dass ich nicht
bei ihm sein können willst du dass er
gehen kann oder nicht
oder muss ich dir zuerst zeigen wieviel
schnitte ich auf meinem körper habe ich
keine angst
vermisst du auch nicht sicher bist du ja
ohne euch fühle ich mich als hätte man
mir das herz aus dem leib gerissen
ich nehme dein herz und verschlucke ist
so ist ein herz immer in meinem team
stimmt gib mir noch einen kuss bevor wir
schluss machen ich lese es vor wie aus
der im café hervorgeht leidet ahmed an
einem spalt wirbel weshalb er an den
rollstuhl gebunden ist zusätzlich wurde
ihm eine schwere hüftluxation
diagnostiziert und er soll nun in der
schön klinik in münchen einer schweren
operation unterzogen werden
wir bitten sie deshalb um die erteilung
einer humanitären aufenthaltsbewilligung
für die mutter damit sie während dieser
zeit nach deutschland kommen kann
er hat den kontakt
vielen dank
wer in und sie sichert sie ja sicher
und ihr wollt jetzt dass die mutter zu
acht mitgehen kann also name und vorname
hier gemacht
danke tschüss sie sagen sie erinnern
sich noch gut an ahmed an was denn vor
allem ich bin ganz gerührt
das ist verständlich
ich habe ihn
[Musik]
ich habe ihn oft gesehen
in dieses rechteck in der mitte kleben
wir das gleiche foto das im
klassenzimmer hängt das mit ahmed und
uns allen und truhen schreibt ihr eure
namen aber nicht zu lang
sonst kann die frau ist nicht lesen sie
ist auch in pension geht dem jemand ein
paar blätter damit ich sie auch hierauf
legen kann
klar auch die kinder dürfen
unterschreiben wenn sie wollen
[Musik]
wir sammeln unterschriften die wir an
angela merkel schicken werden
[Musik]
662 aus rovereto arena
4087 unterschriften
[Applaus]
[Musik]
da ist dir da ist er ja hallo ich bin
ganz schnell hier gefahren wenn ich nur
für mich kochen reicht das oder ja das
reicht das in zwiebeln
die musst du klein hatten aber für dich
allein reicht ein viertel von dem siehst
du du kannst du schon dass ich daran wie
du den kochlöffel jetzt sind es liegt
dass hier jeweils vor dem essen sind
sehr schön die nicht auf italienisch
sage nicht dieses pipi nein so wie er es
in der schule lernt wir kommen auf
unsere anfrage für ein touristenvisum
für ahmed und fall am us mutter katia
ich lese ich den brief vor
wir danken ihnen für ihre e mail an das
generalkonsulat erben
auf wiedersehen kann deborah danke dass
ihr gekommen sollte ich danke euch auf
wiedersehen grüße an alle in giubiasco
[Musik]
meine freunde
ja wir werden sie grüßen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es ist verständlich dass ahmed mutter
nach der jahrelangen trennung nach
deutschland kommen möchte um den lohn
nach der operation zusammen mit dem
vater beizustehen
gleichzeitig ist die erteilung eines
visums nicht möglich wenn eine rückkehr
der asylsuchenden nicht genügend
gesichert werden kann
aufgrund der tatsache dass sich der mann
und die söhne vermutlich nicht legal in
europa aufhalten und das zurzeit in
deutschland ein asylverfahren für sie
hängig ist können wir nicht von einer
sicheren rückkehr ausgehen
ich habe angst
daher kann in dieser situation kein
dringendes touristenvisum erteilt werden
[Musik]
bislang komme ich gleich zu bringen
es wird alles gut gehen
ja das sind dafür
besser als andere seite und andere seite
liegen es wird hier bald besser gehen
du wirst sehen es geht vorbei ich muss
die augen schließen und herausfinden wer
mich berührt werden rührt sich jetzt ich
heute dein papa du und wo rechte ich
sehr gut durchnässt mich entschuldige
ist es so besser was versichern
er berührte ich jetzt
[Musik]
ein kleiner liebling wie schön du spürst
deine füße geht mir als handy ich will
nicht dass er sich nicht geklagt mit
diesem riesen gibt
ich bete zu gott dass er sich rascher
gottseidank hacker durch mir gott helfe
[Musik]
sind wir da
das legendär wie hübsch das schön ist es
hier und auch schön war ja jetzt ist das
heißt vertrieben ist echt schön
wohin gehen wir
da lang schneller
immerhin hast du mich erschreckt gehe
ich kenne ich nicht
warte
ich glaube sie neben den ganz weg gibt
es ganz hart man kann ihn kaum
aufschlagen
[Musik]
hongkong mir ist ganz schwindlig was die
empfohlen das gerade auf die welt
gekommen ist
meine beine sind ganz steif ich kann sie
kaum bewegen heute schon er ist
natürlich anstrengend in der lage seit
sechs wochen nur auf wirken
ponchos ja dass er verschiedene schools
wirklich warum muss er nina beschränken
doch nicht so
weiter gewinnen sind für den schotten
so meinte steht leverkusen auf den
strecken gut
gut machst du das sehr gut
[Musik]
liebe arme fast vier jahre sind
vergangen seit dir deine mama deine
schwester leila und dein bruder raúl im
irak zurück gelassen habt
ich frage mich ob du beim einschlafen
neben deinem papa immer noch jeden abend
die gleiche frage stellt wann kommt man
eigentlich zu den müttern aus giubiasco
sind weitere mütter hinzugekommen auch
aus münchen
sie haben alles versucht um eine antwort
auf deine frage zu erhalten
aber es kam keine doch dann eineinhalb
jahre nachdem ihr die schweiz verlassen
habt erhält dir das recht in deutschland
zu bleiben und dann die große neuigkeit
meine lieben nach all den vergeblichen
versuchen scheint endlich etwas in gang
zu kommen
khadija wurde auf die deutsche botschaft
im irak bestellt hoffen wir dass es
diesmal klappt und ahmet mutter bald
nachkommen kann
um 9 uhr 45 es ist nicht kalt von ihr
hast du alle dokumente ja es liegt alles
bereit
hörst du heute abend
ich habe schon so viel gebetet dass mit
der kopf platzt seit vier jahren bin ich
ständig am b du kannst sicher sein dass
ich es heute auch tue
ich glaube mein bruder kann nicht mehr
so gut italienisch
ich habe den eindruck er weiß nicht dass
walliser koffer heißt walliser ist doch
ein total einfaches wort
das ist die tasche wo man die kleider
und alles rein tot wenn man woanders
hinziehen
stimmt aber weißt du inzwischen habe ich
mich schon ein bisschen daran gewöhnt
ohne hammer zu sein
ich habe mich daran gewöhnt und jetzt wo
sie kommt
ich weiß nicht weißt du warum ich jetzt
immer so schöne sachen
all diese sachen mache ich mir meine
mama welche sachen gehen und das alles
das machst du für obama und für meine
ganze familie
[Musik]
leider besteht
die partei unter anderem
[Musik]
diese sendung wurde ihnen präsentiert
von br genießen sie cremige rezepte mit
bergmann der tübinger genuss seit 1922